[Music]
how
I think with these urban murals
we have also achieved that young people
I turned to see his grandparents because we have
shown that they are also important
for our community and they give me
gives the impression that if there has been more
interest on the part of young people is
sit down to talk with their grandparents and
know its history
[Music]
or
usually they are people who are not
taken into account that's why we've decided
turn to see those people who
another way hardly anyone is going to
honor
[Music]
people know the characters to
difference from other characters maybe
historical where people see them but
these characters see them very far
locals, people appropriate them because
it's the neighbor because it's the grandma
because it's aunt
and that has been very positive for our
community people feel very
proud
ah
[Music]
It has cost a lot a lot, I liked it because
to portray me they took me out better is very
nice because I thought that I
God gives you
[Music]